we're an off-site facility of the
Natural History Museum that's not open
to the public this is the skull of a
humpback whale our collection of marine
mammals is the second largest collection
in North America this hole right here is
where the I would have been when it was
still alive we have approximately 5,000
specimens and that includes dolphins
whales seals sea lions I consider myself
the current steward of the collection I
think of the term whale warehouse as
kind of endearing when people come to
the warehouse definitely I think the
first thing that is noticed it is the
smell but has a musty museum smell but
because of the marine mammals having a
lot of oils and and lipids there's
definitely a smell of rancid oils we
have jars filled with various kinds of
specimens oh yeah this is nice these are
eyeballs most people I've warned in
advance that you know this is what you
need to understand the place is like you
know it's it's not tourist attraction
the warehouse has several different
functions and and one is to serve as a
storage facility for the oversized
specimens but it's also the facility
where we actually prepare new specimens
we're part of the National marine mammal
stranding Network we respond to dead
stranded marine mammals and most of what
we've learned about these species as a
result of studying them closely
we have specimens that have been around
for decades or even more the collection
really is of international significance
if you're a marine mammal researcher and
you've probably been here some of the
recent research includes things like
global climate processes and and how
that has changed over time
I'm a scientist and I'm a little bit
removed from emotional aspect of things
but I still appreciate the majesty of
these incredibly large charismatic
animals and it's it's difficult to not
be affected emotionally by the kinds of
things that we're setting animals that
are on the verge of extinction what are
we going to do about that